Mr. Zuckerberg, let me start with you.
Did I hear you say in your opening
statement that there's no link between
mental health and social media use?
>> This constant exposure is not good for
the developing mind of young people.
This also would include really bad cases
of like cutting and things like that.
>> And so you're seeing a correlation
between this and social media.
>> We're not supposed to be in a fish tank
ourselves.
>> The Instagram families, everything looks
completely perfect. It was one about a
Mormon family and the lady, the mother,
she was, you know, pushing it out and
getting all these views and everybody
saw like this perfect mother.
>> Weird thing started happening. Ruby said
the children were demonically possessed.
>> Social media fries your brain.
Absolutely destroys it. Absolutely kills
it. So why are we still doing it? Dr.
Walsh, Eric Walsh, thank you so much for
joining us. You've done many topics,
conversations about social media on the
brain. Let's get into it. Yes, this is
this is a major topic and as a physician
as well as as someone who preaches uh we
are seeing the ramifications of the last
15 16 years of excessive social media
use um and so now as a church I think
and as a society maybe even more
importantly we have to begin to start
looking at what's happening and bringing
things back. I was listening to
something by one of the governors, I
think she's the governor of Arkansas,
Huckabe, um and she was saying that, you
know, they're about to ban um
smartphones and cell phones in schools
and that there are other states that are
looking at doing this because after a
while now, the science is beginning to
pile up that in fact this constant
exposure is not good for the developing
mind of young people who, as we know,
their frontal lobe doesn't fully develop
until they're about 25 years old. So you
have this new thing. It's like an
experiment in the human uh saga that has
launched on the scene and it has changed
everything. And so I want to start if we
can just look at kind of um some of
what's happened. This is the teen
depression statistics in the US. Um when
you look at it, uh 20% of American
teenagers express experienced
depression. Uh 50% increase in teenage
depression between 2011 and 2015. So
we've been watching this change. And
here's us teens with major depression.
You can see that there's been a massive
increase. What I want the audience to
look at is when does this thing begin to
really change? Look here. And you can
see that it's flat. At about 2010, it
starts to come up. That's major
depression. This are these are US teens
admitted uh hospitalized for nonfatal
self harm, right? Between ages 10 and
14. And you can see for girls, massive
increase by 2020. I mean this is so this
doesn't even include the mental health
damage experienced um and overlays this
during the pandemic.
>> So this is just like attempts of
selfdeion or
>> some of it exactly
>> that and and and this probably this also
would include really bad cases of like
cutting and things like that which I see
in I've seen in practice
>> and so you're seeing a correlation
between this and social media. Yes.
>> Yeah. I I think this same study, I don't
know if you're going to show this or
not, but um they even looked at
socioeconomic status. I mean, they were
trying to understand, well, is it just
that like like a certain demographic of
people that are experiencing that and
they went through and looked at like
like location, race, this that I mean,
dude, all of them. It was like all of
them same thing.
>> There's another one though. Look at
anxiety. This is a big one. In fact, in
Luke 21, Jesus says, "Men's hearts
failing them for fear."
>> Anxiety is an end time uh hallmark. And
you can see here that when you look at
it, these are massive increases in
anxiety prevalence. In fact, in some
studies, it's the number one reason
overall for people to see a doctor in
the United States.
>> Anxiety is a massive thing. Um,
>> and so you can see here, one in five US
teens experienced depression. So, I want
to walk let's go, let's look at the
timeline of this thing.
>> Here's a great graphic. The evolution of
smartphones,
>> 2007.
I remember in the 80s and 90s like you
just had this like huge telephone thing.
It looked like you were like like in the
Vietnam or something, you know, and then
it moved to like this little bag that
you could carry around in your car. And
I always thought that was cool. Like
whoa, you can make a telephone call from
your car.
>> Yeah.
>> And eventually they released in in the
late 2000s the the iPhone. And I was
just watching a video of Steve Jobs
explaining that they will no longer like
the other phones before like
Blackberries had actual keyboards on
them, buttons on them. He's like, "We're
not going to do this anymore. It's just
going to be a flat screen." He explains
and it's new technology that allow you
to basically do data input directly onto
this flat screen. And he said it, it's
going to change everything.
>> Yep. It has.
>> And he was right. Yeah, I you know I'm
one of those statistics you were showing
earlier because like I I'm from the
Netherlands and I remember when I think
Google bought YouTube and it was on the
news and I watched it and I was like
what's YouTube? You know, it was like
not that big of a thing yet. And so
there was this particular trend in the
Netherlands and I was like I'll make a
funny video about that. Put it on
YouTube. Lost my password. Couldn't get
back in to remove it, you know, like
tried all kinds of ways to get my
password back. Here it was. And
everybody in my school saw it and I was
looking silly and stupid and I got
bullied and I got severely depressed.
>> Mercy.
>> And so you can see this was like the
early 2000s. That was when this was just
becoming a thing. There was no
Instagram. Like Facebook was barely
alive, you know, barely a thing for
people my age at the time. Like it was
like some people had it, some people
didn't. Now that's way worse. Now you
put something out there and the world
sees it, you know,
>> and I think it's really emboldened
people to like be mean because if you're
not standing there face to face with
somebody. Yeah. People kind of can be
like this like super horrible on a
keyboard and they probably would never
do that to your face, you know?
>> Oh no. This and and I mean we've we kind
of experienced it. We see so we saw this
massive increase in all of the different
some of these like Tik Tok isn't I mean
um
>> uh Twitter isn't even Twitter anymore,
>> right? And so the question comes the big
question comes here. Is social media
actually bad for your health?
>> I believe it.
>> Yeah.
>> 100%.
>> Well, I I I think like like anything,
right? Uh the majority of how people use
this technology is probably like super
bad. There there are people that I mean
we use social media. We put things out
on it. You churches use social media.
They you know put their sermons on it
and stuff like this. So, so you know, I
think it's the way that people are
putting this information out and
digesting this information in this very
selfish way that's making it. But I I I
want to just throw that comment out
there. I I think that there are some
people that are actually putting good
things out there.
>> This is true. This is true. I mean,
technically, YouTube is a form of social
media. We post shorts sometimes and and
there's ways to use social media for
good.
>> Yeah.
>> But you go on someone's social media
site and it's all like, "Look at me.
Look at the vacation I'm on. Look at the
new clothes I bought." Yes, that's
that's that's a bad use of the
technology.
>> But it's like television as you know
we'll talk about later but um you know
television in general it has these
inherent characteristics
>> that weakens the mind. It does right
>> um but you can use television for good
right I mean you think about like
amazing facts or when CD Brooks used to
be on TV preaching I mean reaching
millions of people in ways you know you
you otherwise just couldn't. But we have
to understand that each one of these is
a tool and the devil loves these tools.
>> So you we can use them but we have to
respect the tool.
>> That's right. And understand how it
works. I mean if you don't understand
how it works you could easily get sucked
down a road that's like you don't want
to be there.
>> Yeah.
>> So um we we're so there's a lot now on
the mental health and its impacts from
all of this. Um and you know this the
World Health Organization basically
saying listen we've got to change the
way we look at it. I mean this isn't
like American. They're like globally
this is creating fits is what the World
Health Organization is saying.
>> And even teenagers themselves this is
this study are worried they spend too
much time on their phone. So even the
teenagers are like man you know I wish I
didn't spend so much time on my phone.
>> You know you you spoke about um schools
contemplating not having this. I've
actually been to some schools where they
do not let them have phones um
boardingmies where um they you have to
surrender the phone when you go there
and then um um I think if you if you go
home on the weekends or whatever like
that they can give you the phone back.
Um and I asked the students directly
straight out, do you like this? And they
said we love it. I mean, it's like that
pressure off of you and you can actually
like engage in your relationships and
you know nowadays like a a happening
party is like people doing this.
>> Yeah. You know when you go to a
restaurant and you see married couples
on a date and that's what they do.
>> Yeah. It's sad.
>> It's like
>> like I'm sitting there with my husband.
I'm like but that's sad. Like where is
the connection between two people that
are in love?
>> Culturally we're we're losing the art of
just communicating,
>> right?
>> Yep. And it's it's going to impact young
people even more because many of them
>> are going to be asked at some point to
step out of the virtual world into the
real world. And we're already seeing
there are a lot of things changing fast.
For example,
>> um marriages are happening later and
later to your point, but even intimacy.
So if you go back to the 60s and 70s and
' 80s, you saw a kind of a graph of the
increases. Wasn't nearly as bad as we
thought it was among teenagers.
Increases in actual like sexual
involvement. Now it's going down
>> because they get it online.
>> Because they can they they're finding
ways to do all this stuff through online
pornography, social media, the
connections they want, they can get that
same dopamine play without ever having
to be vulnerable to an actual person.
And this is the problem cuz when you
follow uh organizations like Fight the
New Drug, they talk about how the people
in in the minds of people who watch porn
on a regular basis,
>> the um women in the porn videos become
products and they even have t-shirts
that says people over products, which I
highly respect. I appreciate that. But
yeah, like you basically objectify the
person instead of it like no, this is
actually an individual that has
feelings, that has emotions. That's a
creation of God.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, God God made us social and
he made us like the relationship was
always from the beginning like you know
he creates Adam and he's like you know
even with all of this beauty and
everything like this it's still not good
for him to be alone and created him a
wife you know and so it's like from the
onset we have this need for social
interaction that's like the devil has
just artificially like pacified us.
>> Yeah. And and it's and it's really
frightening because when you look at how
the church survives the time of trouble,
>> um you have to be able to connect to
those
>> who will strengthen you and disconnect
from those who won't. Yes.
>> Social media is going to make that or or
I should say an addiction to social
media is going to make that process much
more difficult.
>> Y true.
>> So couple of let me let me a couple of
the scientific things here. This is one
of the studies from the one of the the
the surgeon general's advisory. I think
key takeaways from there. Social media
use young people is nearly universal. Up
to 95% of young people aed 13 to 17
report using a social media platform.
Nearly 2/3 of teenagers report using
social media every day and one-third
report using social media.
>> Almost
>> constantly. I can't remember what the
statistic is of how often people check
their phones, but it was like every f
five or 10 minutes or something like
that. I mean, all day long. And I and I
saw this like really funny video one
time and the psychologist was talking
about it and saying, you know, you're
sitting here scrolling like this on your
phone, right? Let's say you you had a
dog or a cat and if your dog or cat was
sitting in the corner of your room
sitting there doing this, you'd think
something was wrong with it.
>> You know what I mean? It's like what a
weird world we live in that that's what
people
>> and the way that they design social
media is so that you scroll up because
inherently as a human you think if I'm
doing if I'm doing that I'm going to hit
a bottom. Yeah,
>> there's got to be a
a floor to it.
>> And so they've designed it so that when
you do this, you're waiting to reach a
floor that doesn't exist.
>> And with each with each thing you view,
>> we don't realize we're sending data back
to these companies as to what we're
interested in. So now they populate it
with more of what you're interested in.
We I mean, and I don't know if it I
don't know if it's just an old wives
tale or or an urban legend, but my wife
and I find this all the time. We'll say
something in the house.
>> Oh, yeah. pick up the phone and I'm
like, Jackie, weren't we talking about
buying one of these?
>> It's Look at this. It's advertised on
this. And we're like, oh, weird.
Everybody's experienced it.
>> So, we, you know, this thing is it's
connecting us and and I want to remember
that. I want us to be reminded that the
that one day we will not be able to buy
and sell.
>> Yeah.
>> Unless we have the mark of the beast.
That's right. And you can see already
that in a way in that would have been
inconceivable when that verse was taught
in the 60s7s or even the 80s that that
that verse has new meaning today because
of the way we do business through
smartphones and social media on and on
and on. So I I want to just highlight
this. This one says social media
presents a meaningful risk of harm to
youth while also providing benefits to
your point earlier. The types of use and
content children and adolescence are
exposed to pose mental health concerns.
Children and adolescence who spend more
than three hours a day on social media
face double the risk of mental health
problems including experiencing symptoms
of depression and anxiety. This is
concerning as a recent survey showed
that teenagers spend on an average of
three and a half hours a day on social
media. Three hours is the threshold for
mental health problems. The average is
three and a half. And when asked about
the impact of social media on their body
image, 46% of adolescence aged 13 to 17
said social media makes them feel worse.
>> Wow.
>> I can't imagine.
>> I believe it because everybody's only
putting their their best moments on. And
the filters I see, I don't know. I don't
know anything about this, but I remember
somebody did a picture of me and put a
filter and maybe gave you like doggy
ears and like a I said, "Man, you better
take that thing down. That's crazy
looking." And so, you know, I mean, it
was just on their phone, but you got
Yeah. Take it off. So, these filters can
actually make people look even I guess
you can actually correct people like
like CGI. I don't know.
>> Yeah. I I've seen like collages of
people that that would show you what
they really look like and then what they
and it's just like, wow, that's totally
cheating. And so then if you're always
seeing all these like beautiful people,
how can you not be like, well, I know I
don't look like that, you know? And it's
like just psychologically you feel less
than or broken and
>> well and I think that there's also
something for everybody because for the
teenagers it's like the other women who
are like really skinny and all that kind
of stuff but like for my age category
you know I'm married and no kids yet but
maybe in the future and then you they
have like the Instagram families with
like the even the Christian Instagram
families who have like the perfect
lifestyle. They live in Hawaii. They're
like surfing with their kids and they
have like Bible verses stuff, but like
everything looks completely perfect and
they're all models, you know, and so
it's but it's like but you probably have
arguments with your spouse at some point
and you probably have a kid that starts
crying. You have to have a poopy diaper
and but that's not being shown. So it's
like a perfect utopia and yeah, I'm sure
that that does something with your
brain, you know.
>> There was a documentary man was it on
Netflix or on or on um Amazon? But there
was one and someone suggested it. So we
watched it. Um and it was one about a
Mormon family and the lady the mother
she did like the like you're describing.
So she had like this perfect thing. They
had all these kids and the kids would do
perform things and do things and she was
you know pushing it out and getting all
these views and everybody saw like this
perfect mother. By the time this
documentary is over, I mean, it spooked
me. Like, she moves this woman in and
the woman, I guess, is attracted to the
mother to move the father out of the
bedroom. Just a crazy story. And I'm
glad I don't remember the name of it cuz
maybe nobody should watch it. But the
woman that comes in is actually
demonpossessed.
>> Oh, wow.
>> What?
>> And they and um you can hear on this
documentary, which is just a regular
documentary, this demon possession, the
woman speaking in the in the voice of
the demon.
>> What? Uh, and by the end of it, the
family's completely destroyed.
>> And the whole point of documentary is it
started like you said, this family was
supposed to be like this perfect family.
But by shining all this attention on the
kids, it destroyed the kids. It
destroyed the marriage. It destroyed
everything because we're not supposed to
be uh in a fish tank ourselves.
>> Right. And when you focus everything on
you, one, you get an exaggerated sense
of self. Right.
>> Right. and you want more and more and
more. So, what I'm not talking about
here is the dopamineergic the brain side
of this. There is a hit that gets every
you get in your brain a release of
dopamine and pleasure every time you
pick up your phone and see that you have
a message from someone or you get what
they say really gets you is when you
pick up your social media and there's a
like
>> or you start tracking how many views
you've gotten and it's growing or the
likes are growing and people are making
good comments. There's a dopamine
release. It's almost and dopamine is the
is the neurochemical of addiction.
>> So now you get to a point where you need
more and more and more. Well, how do you
get more and more likes, more and more
uh uh views, you have to begin to
transform yourself in what you think
people will like and watch.
>> So you by default you're now taking
yourself and changing yourself. We are
either molding our minds to receive the
seal of God or the mark of the beast. M
>> the mark of the beast is a statement
that I want to be liked by the world.
>> Yeah.
>> And social media to me prepares the mind
for that.
>> That's true. I think life is daily
little choices that are like
repetitiously setting you up for
something down the road. And yeah, and
that's an excellent point. I haven't
really thought of it from that
perspective, but every single thing that
you do is preparing you for that stand.
And if you can't stand on social media,
you're getting swayed left and right or
you're posting things that I don't
really really believe that, but I I
don't want to be honest with what I
actually believe about that. Yeah,
that's going to be a hard that's going
to be a hard time when you come to that
point that you really need to make a
choice.
>> Right.
>> Before we came on, we were talking about
what I went through with the city of
Pasadena and the state of Georgia.
>> Um,
>> for real quick for for our viewers, just
real quick cap. So, I was I was invited
to be the the um commencement speaker
for um a college in Southern California.
And um they disinvited um uh an activist
for the LGBTQ community. He really
should have been the one who speaks. I
will be the first to admit it. He was an
Oscar award winner, graduate of the
school. I had no connection to the
school. I clearly have never won and
never will win an Oscar. Um and so they
disinvited him. Students were really
upset about it. And so the president of
the of the college had heard me speak
for the mayor's prayer breakfast before
that a couple years earlier really
wanted me to speak um and so put me
pushed me into the spot in a sense of I
put put me in the spot and when the
students found out there was just like
an uproar from a small group of the
students but really upset that this
person they wanted to speak had been
disinvited. So they went online to find
a way to um discredit me and all they
found were my sermons and they took
things out of context and basically you
know really you know really really came
against me from that perspective. Um and
long story short we went through a long
legal battle in the end and and God
delivered and all of that but uh it was
really ugly. What I want to I want to
bring this back to social media because
again this was it's about 13 uh 11 years
ago now that it all started. Um what
social media did was add fuel to a fire
in a way that if this had happened 20
years earlier couldn't have happened. It
would have just been a little local
thing. No big deal. It became
international national news.
>> I remember hearing about it. Um but
social media can persecute in a way and
that didn't exist before social media
your reputation.
>> So a lot of people think well you know
persecution is going to be the stake or
you know I'm going to be scorged or I'm
going to be imprisoned or I'm going be
killed. I want people to understand that
the way social media works persecution
can actually come by simply the
destruction of your reputation.
>> Right? Mhm. So it's like a living record
that
>> and that's why young people need to be
very to your point earlier very careful
what they post. They actually need to
put as little up as possible unless it's
just a simple clean statement. It's
>> true.
>> The less you put up is going to be the
better in the long run. And so that
damage to my reputation, the fact that
they came at me that way was as harmful,
maybe more harmful than if that if I had
have been persecuted like they would
have persecuted me during the, you know,
during the dark ages. to make that
point. There's a great book called The
Heavenly Man.
>> If you if no one's read that book, it's
a great book. Brother Yun, Brother Yun,
>> uh Christian pastor in communist China,
>> imprisoned, beaten, persecuted, horrible
things happened to this man in communist
China all in the last like 30 years. So,
it's not like old stuff. This is modern,
you know, history. And he says after he
came to North America, a journalist in
California posted something saying that
brother Yun was a liar and what he's
saying is not true attacked his
reputation. You know what brother Yun
says in that book?
>> He says that that was worse
>> than all the persecution he received in
communist China.
>> What happened to him in North America
around his reputation.
>> Wow.
>> I say that for people to begin to
understand you've got to you're going to
have to develop thick skin.
>> Yep.
>> Right. Around your reputation. You're
going to have to we're going to have to
have to be people who are not afraid to
be disliked.
>> And right now, I don't know that the
church is there yet. People want to be
liked so bad
>> that it will it will open the door to
compromise.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, you know, this the social media
thing makes that point. Brother Yun
really makes that point. And I can tell
you it is one of the most uncomfortable
things to be beat up like this and not
be able to really in any effective way
all at once defend yourself.
>> Yeah. I I heard that um when the social
media started to incorporate some of
these tools with like the like button
and stuff like that, what they were
really trying to do was find different
ways to keep you on the platform and
like you said the dopamine that you're
getting released and and stuff, you
know, like any drug, you need more and
more and more, right? So, you've got to
find more reasons to get that to get
that little add a boy. And so, you know,
you are playing with the chemistry of
your body. And even some of these social
media sites when they release something
and and and I saw this and it was
amazing. This guy broke this down one
time. Pay attention to this. They'll
send you a funny video. They'll send you
something that makes you mad. They'll
send you something that goes, "Oh,
that's cute." They'll send you something
that's like seductive. They'll send you
something and it they rotate through
these um these emotions so that you are
actually on this emotional roller
coaster. And that is something that's
built into addiction in itself. So, it's
like if you're getting mad at somebody
and then all of a sudden it's like Yeah.
and you're feeling good over here, it's
like they constantly keep your emotions
on this like roller coaster and that in
itself is addicting.
>> That's right. Very true.
>> I want to hit I want to hit one more of
these. This is the proportional risk of
mental health problems by social media
time among us teens. And as you can see,
the more social media exposure, the more
likely you are to have mental health
problems. Someone in my family, someone
close to me,
>> a teenager actually did commit suicide
>> and due to social media
>> and social media was a key part of it.
Um, from what we heard from the police,
um, this person was being, this young
girl, she my little cousin of mine was
being bullied.
>> Um,
>> and we even think that someone actually,
this is one of the reasons I do this
talk is that someone actually was
coaching her as to how to do it. M
>> so someone she met online um her
siblings say that they saw her going
into the bathroom
>> on the phone before this all happened
>> and as and the police said there are
people who literally target kids
>> and will coach them into this
>> um from a distance.
>> Lord have mercy.
>> Um so I don't you know obviously it's
impossible to really know more than that
because there's no way to talk to the
people who did it
>> except to say I mean this thing and
that's where we're going to go now. It
gets dark. Yeah.
>> And I want people, Christian people, to
know the devil only has a he's limited.
There are rules of engagement in a great
controversy.
>> Heartbreak.
>> All right. I can do this.
All right.
[Music]
There are conventional ways of sharing
the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things. Um, never
mind. A way that gets the message out
with confidence.
>> Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean?
>> Oh, thank you. You know, we're all made
with a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork.
>> Wow. Where'd you get it?
>> Lightwear. Wear your witness.
[Music]
When I was growing up, my mother was a
single mother. I was a latch key kid. I
wore a shoe string with a key around my
neck, literally, and went to school and
back. My mother was a single mom, so she
was at work. We'd open the door, shut
the door, and my mother had one rule,
and you both probably can figure out the
rule.
>> Do not open the door when you get home.
That's it. You stay inside. If someone
knocks at the door, you do not open the
door. Don't engage. Just leave them
outside because, you know, we lived in a
suburb, but still, you know, just
there's no reason for you to answer the
door. you know, there was no there was
no Amazon back then. Nothing's coming.
Just leave the door shut.
>> Um,
>> today though, I can leave that door
locked and through television, through
music, through social media, through the
smartphone,
texting and and chatting and so forth. I
can open all kinds of doors to my
children and to myself. Mhm.
>> As Christians, if we are going to be
prepared for what is coming upon the
world, the doors have to be shut.
>> Amen.
>> We cannot give the devil that kind of
access to our families,
>> to ourselves as adults. I think I like
what you said because a lot of times we
talk about this and we talk to
teenagers, but adults are just as,
>> you know, able to become addicted to
this stuff as anyone else.
>> They really are. I I have had many
conversations with even elderly people
that are lonely and you know when giving
a talk like this on this particular
subject and talking about like you know
between the hours of 11 and 3 in the
morning you should not be like paying
attention to this blue light you know
it's like having damage on your
circadian rhythms. That's right.
>> And uh I had a a sweet little lady come
up to me and she was just like I
completely stay up all night long and do
this. So it's not just the young people.
It's like this can touch anyone and suck
you into it.
>> And why does the devil want us sucked
into this? Because just like, and I like
that you brought up the point earlier,
just as these tools can be used for
evangelism, and we need to I want to I
just heard a pastor at a pastor's
retreat, a pastor from South Carolina
who uses Facebook advertising to invite
people to evangelistic crusades, certain
radius. You can target people who, you
know, Facebook is very sophisticated.
You can set them offering free books,
free, you know, hey, if you, you know,
based on their interest on Facebook, a
free copy of the great controversy, your
desire of ages or whatever it is, you
can find out who's really interested
with much less work than you would have
done, you know, 40 years ago by
targeting the people who already there's
evidence through Facebook they would
want this content. So you can use it for
good,
>> right? So that that we have to say, but
if it can be used for good, Satan has
the advantage that he can lie. M
>> so he can actually in in a in in a sense
in a multiplied fashion use it for evil.
And that's where I want us to go for the
end of this.
>> I I want to submit that there are
prophetically a few things that have to
happen.
>> We know that there is an apostate
uh uh uh church that those that have
that have fallen away from the Bible
there false revivals going on now.
Social media is a big part of that. We
know that especially with the election
of this last pope, there's a
strengthening of the arm of Catholicism
in the world,
>> which is prophesied. And anyone here who
doesn't know about those prophecies,
reach out to us. We can get that to you.
>> Yeah, we've got a video we can put in a
description about who the antichrist is.
And I I do want to say that we're not
saying this in any way to attack
Catholics or anything like that. Being
respectful, we're just discussing Bible
prophecy, the system. Yeah. We're not
talking about genuine Catholic.
>> Exactly. my family, I have a lot of
Catholic family, so I'm definitely not
doing that.
>> But I but the third arm of it is
spiritualism.
>> Yeah,
>> that's from Revelation chapter 16. Um,
and we we take that verse that says,
"And out of the mouth of the false
prophet, out of the mouth of the beast,
out of the mouth of the dragon came
three unclean spirits like frogs." Those
are the three unclean spirits.
Spiritualism is a big part of that
because these things go and they seduce
and deceive the kings of the world. If
the devil is going to make social
spiritualism on par with the billions of
Christians who are either, you know,
Protestant, Catholic, whatever they are,
something radical has to happen in the
world. And I want to submit to the
audience, it's happening.
>> It's happened
>> and we are on a breakthrough. So, let me
let me just show you that. So, here
>> this is from Wired. It says, "Tik Tok
has become the home of modern
witchcraft." Oh wow. And and before you
dive into this, I got to just tell you
like I watched this breakdown of how Tik
Tok actually works. Mindblowing. Do you
know how long it'll take Tik Tok to
figure you out?
>> You said 40 minutes, right?
>> 40 minutes. Like it can know nothing
about you. Not a thing at all. And just
by the way that you pause on what video,
it can completely figure you out. And
then what it does is like so it it shows
you popular videos that could be in the
millions or whatever like this. And
based on which popular video you choose,
it's like, "Oh, wow. he likes dogs. So
then it'll start sending you dogs and
then you let you click on one that's
like I like French bulldogs. And then
all of a sudden it sends you nothing but
French bulldogs. So if you stop and
pause on something that's about
witchcraft, it's going to go, "Oh, you
have an interest in witchcraft and then
it's going to just do nothing but feed
you witchcraft 40 minutes into the
line."
>> The fastest growing religion among young
people in America is wicker and
witchcraft. Yeah.
>> And I was just in the UK. Um, and while
I was in Canada earlier this summer,
this thing is huge. One of the pastors
in in London told me this a few years
back that for every Christian pastor in
London, there are 30 witches.
>> Oh, wow.
>> And all weekend these witches pray for
the destruction of Christian churches.
>> And he said one of the maybe he, you
know, he he couldn't make a a matter of
fact statement. He said, but possibly
one of the evidences of this is that the
churches in England are becoming pubs
>> and mosques rather than churches
anymore.
>> That in fact this is happening. One of
the interesting things and there's a you
know um even men like uh Donald Trump,
Putin, Charlie Kirk, people who people
really find controversial may may or may
not like. They've there are evidence
that people actually are putting spells
on all of these people as well.
>> So I mean and so let's say you don't
like any of those three. Well, they if
they can put spells on them, they can
put spells on anyone. Yeah.
>> Right. And so, there is a new world
where these things are unveiled. And
we'll talk more about them in some other
sessions, but these things are being
unveiled and released onto society where
spiritualism. So, so let me look at a
couple have a couple more of these.
Witch Talk, the witchcraft videos with
billions of views.
>> Billions.
>> Billions of views. Crazy. And it's
called Witch Talk, not Tik Tok. It's
inside Tik Tok, but they call it Witch
Talk. And so here's one Mitchto. The
rise of the occult on social media has
eerie parallels with the 16th century.
>> I remember a while ago I was working on
some kind of a video. I don't even
remember what topic it was on. It was an
LD live show and I was looking for some
videos on on Wishcraft and social media
and I remember just seeing this girl who
was like, "Yeah, and so here's my
crystals and here's like my my tarot
cards." And they made it look like it
was like this just like this cutesy
thing that we're just gonna do, you
know? And I was like, "But that's
witchcraft." And like back in the
heyday, like the Salem witch trials,
like people were not having it, you
know? Not saying we should do that now,
but what I'm saying is that the mindset
of people has completely shifted. It's
popular now to become witches, like you
said, because of Tik Tok.
>> One of the things that fueled this
during the um COVID and the shutdown was
people felt powerless. And they say that
as they were home digging around on the
internet and this stuff's just like
prevalent all over the place, it was
like offering you power for, you know,
like something where like now I can
control this. And that's really what
it's about. It's like I want to control
the elements. I want to control the
things. And I mean, it's really taking
the miracles and the position that God
has for us away from God and going, I'm
going to put it in my own hands.
>> Yep.
>> Well, we got it. It's been served to
society. Um, and you know, we did one on
just spiritualism. It starts with shows
like Bewitched.
>> Yeah.
>> I was listening to CD Brooks preaching
from like the 70s and he brought that
up. He's like Bewitched and The Ghosts
Next Door something. And he was naming
some of these TV shows that seemed
relatively innocent. Scooby Scooby-Doo.
So, you know, and and Scooby-Doo
changed. At first, it was always a hoax
>> the first few seasons. Then it was real
real ghosts and real stuff by the end of
the of the of the show or by the
reiteration of the show. So it was
served in but that just exposed you to
it gave you interest in it. What social
media has done is found a way to make
you participate in it.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. I remember I grew up on Harry
Potter like I was younger and Harry
Potter came out for the first time. Um,
and then after watching the movies, we
started going to the library and reading
the books. And then we got the video
games. And now I was doing it in the
video games. And in my mind, I wanted to
be like Harry Potter. I was actually
saying out loud these spells that I was
supposed to do in the video games
because it becomes real, you know. And
the same thing here. Now they're
teaching you how to actually do it. So,
it's one step further, which back then,
yeah, you did it in a video game and it
made me do it technically, like just say
the spells, but now it's like, no, we're
actually going to teach you how you can
do it.
>> Well, the it is to get people to
participate in this is the devil's goal.
>> And here's the irony. There are many
people who call themselves Christians.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Who are just who are also messing with
the crystals and the spells. And I I
said I I say this kind of as a joke in
my sermons, but I literally walked into
one of the clinics I was managing a few
years ago and um there was a spell
written above the coffee machine.
>> Oh wow.
>> So I walk into the break room of this
clinic and the coffee machine is sitting
here and I don't own the the the clinic.
I just worked there too as the medical
director. So I don't really think I had
>> I had much too much to do with this. I
walk in and above it is a spell written
out and it talks about if you turn the
coffee this way and do this and do this
and do this, it'll make you have a bless
like a whatever day. There was a word
they use wasn't blessed and you'll have
a good day basically.
>> And I'm sitting there like
>> what what this is an actual like and the
spirit of the Lord was like this is real
witchcraft. This isn't someone here is
actually practicing witchcraft. This is
the introduction to everyone else who
works here. Man, I ripped that thing off
the wall so fast. And in the sermon, I
was joking. I wanted to go get like a
super soaker gun and fill it with oil.
Spray over the oil and then anoint the
whole place with oil with a super soaker
gun. Um because this thing has gotten
really real. It's big. It's billions. I
mean, last time I checked, I think it
was 70 or 80 billion views of these
things. And they teach spells. They
teach now. And Harry Potter, just to use
that as an example, those are real
spells.
>> Yeah, that's right. Hey, she those are
real spells. The characters just
appeared to her like the Twilight
person. This is so it's no longer play
stuff.
>> Um and again, so I want to really warn
families, parents, a lot of them have
give their kids a phone and not really
think about what happens afterwards. You
have got to have uh programs on the
phone and on your phone that watches
what they do. You got to sometimes put
two of them on because the kids are so
smart. they can get around their
parents. Like, they're smart enough to
know how to have you watching them on
their phone and still do what they want.
So, you got to really be sophisticated
as a parent. You need to take the phone.
No child should go to bed with their
phone at 6 or 7:00 when they're home
with you who they don't need to talk to
anybody else. Take the phone, put it in
a drawer, give their mind, body, and
eyes so that they get good sleep. Give
them a break from the phone overnight.
>> If your if your child can't separate
with the phone at 6:00, they should not
have a phone.
>> Yeah. Yeah. because that means they're
already too addicted to the phone and
you've got to not allow that to happen.
So, you got to shut this stuff down.
You've got to be the parent. I was I was
at at a camp at a camp meeting this
summer speaking and one of the parents,
you know, we're doing a question and
answer with one of the other pastors and
one of the parents said, "Well, if we
take away their phones, the child would
cancel us."
>> Um, and you know, my thought is, I wish
that kid had my mother. My mother trying
my mother would have canceled you. You
wouldn't cancel her.
>> Um, but you we have to be parents.
>> Yeah. This is not the time to shriek.
And And here's it goes again. You want
your kid to like you. You might get your
kid to like you, but you won't get them
to respect you.
>> Yeah.
>> And ultimately, if you really love your
child,
>> you will it's okay to be disliked for
the moment
>> for their long-term betterment.
>> Right. And for them to understand that
there are some some safety guards that
you as a parent should build into them.
I mean, if if you you told your kid like
if you play with this one thing, you
have a very highly likelihood that
you're going to become a gambling addict
in your life, right? What parent in
their right mind would be like, "Ah,
it's fine. Just play with it." You know,
they're going to build some safety into
it. And I think that we've lost that
ability as a society to say, "Hey, let's
let's build some safeguards around here.
This should not be something that you're
staring at for 11 hours out of the day.
And let's build some family time and
dinner time." And we we do that in my
house, too. My um kids don't have phones
and stuff like that yet. Um they got an
iPad that they'll you know do school
work and stuff like that on and um but
but no actual phone yet and I have a no
technology rule at the table. Like
that's our family time. We we we enter
and as a family don't bring that stuff
when we're when we're doing worship and
you know those kind of things like you
build the times to to say nope this is
this is our sacred time as a family to
interact with each other. Well, and I
think it's also that um
kids watch or act like their parents
act. So if parents are
watching YouTube all day or Facebook or
whatever and then tell the child, well,
you should not do that, then that's very
quickly going to seem unfair to the
child. So yeah, my husband and I were
talking about it because at some point,
you know, we might want to have kids and
we're like, we need to make sure that
now we start practicing less and less of
the phone
>> because we believe when we have kids, we
don't want them to have any interact
with technology whatsoever until they're
the right age.
>> Right?
>> You know, I grew up mostly playing
outside, playing with Legos, playing
with the Barbie dolls, and I'm thankful
for that. I did watch a lot of TV and
video games, but still I was outside a
lot. Didn't social media didn't come in
until I was in my teens.
>> And and I can see the benefit of that
and I can see it for myself when I put
down my phone and I go read a book or
like spend some time with my husband
like we just do a puzzle. It's so much
better. I mean, this might sound
oldfashioned to some people, but I love
puzzles. Great for the brain. You both
are hitting on something I think I also
want to really emphasize for the
audience that what's where social media
may be as damaging if not more damaging
than the actual horrible content we've
discussed its impact on depression and
anxiety is that like a plate of food if
you pile up the plate with jelly beans
there's no space for broccoli
>> right so if you if this is what you're
feeding the family you lose the space
for good family time and the word that
you use that I want to emphasize to kind
of highlight as we go into kind of just
some some verses and stuff to to close
out um is worship.
>> Yeah.
>> What do we worship? Yeah.
>> And the phone itself, social media
itself, my image that I'm trying to
project to others, all of that can
become an idol.
>> Yep.
>> And take away from true worship and the
ability to truly worship. So,
>> one of the things that's lacking and and
and I think there's been a move from the
top of the church about going back to
the altar. I think Dwayne has been at um
the LG Wise Estate has brought this up.
We have got to go back to the altar. And
I want to encourage those who are
watching, strongly encourage you if
you're not having good family worship.
>> But there's a plenty of time on phones,
cancel phone time, cancel TV time,
cancel Netflix, and spend an hour, hour
and a half
>> daily in worship with your family.
Morning and evening.
>> Spend time. come up with an actual and
if you can't do it by yourself, talk to
other people in the church, look it up
online, talk to your pastor. Hopefully,
they can help you. But set up an
intentional curriculum around family
worship. Family worship isn't just hit
or miss. It is a curriculum. You want in
a year, and if you're just a married
couple, no kids, you want in a year to
say, "All right, by the end of this
year, we're going to understand these
key things out of the Bible, or we're
going to have studied these books, the
writings of Paul. We're going to really
know who Paul was by the end of this
year." I encourage you in intentionality
because social media steals
intentionality, right?
>> Yeah, I believe that.
>> Yep. Uh with our family, we we we kind
of even bounce it around, you know, um
sometimes we let the kids lead out in
it. And it's really funny because we've
done it for so long and so many times
that our animals, we have a dog and a
cat, they will come at that time and
they enter into the worship with us like
they're literally there like all the
time. And and to me, it's just like you
we we've built that into our kids'
growing up and and you want to instill
that into them so that they'll carry
that on when they get out of the house.
I mean, 18 years goes by super quick.
I'm already counting the days that like
my daughter's going to be out on her
own. And you know, I'm just like, wow,
whatever I say now is going to be very
important to her life down the road. So,
you know, build those habits in there
now. And if you don't know, like like
you said, just ask God, show me what I
should do or how I should have treat
this and and you'll see it's an amazing
thing to glue your family together.
>> Amen. And and I and I would I would um
emphasize as well um that this, you
know, that time together in family
worship is time that is eternal time.
>> Yeah.
>> When we get to heaven, that time is
still going to have mattered.
>> That's right. Um, so you know, I I I
can't overemphasize that. I want to also
emphasize something I've been talking
about all year is prayer
>> and attending prayer meeting at your
local church.
>> I want to encourage people because
again, one of the big drains of social
media is time. I really want to
encourage people to go to prayer meeting
on Wednesday night or Tuesday night if
your church does it. Then go and pray
with the brethren.
>> It's a different experience than Sabbath
service.
>> It will bolster not only you, your
family, but your church. Good point. So,
I want to really encourage that um as
well. So, let's not lose time. And so,
some people say, "Well, listen, I don't
know. I don't know if I if if my if my
family's too far gone. I'm worried about
my kids. There are those whose kids are
already out of the house and they're no
longer going to church." This is
something we hear everywhere we go.
Isaiah 49 and verse 25 says this, "But
thus sayeth the Lord, even the captives
of the mighty shall be taken away, and
the prey of the terrible shall be
delivered. For I will contend with him
that contends with you, and I will save
your children.
>> Amen.
>> That is a promise.
>> That is a promise. And I want to because
there's somebody that's watching this
that may say, you know, my kids no
longer want to go to church. Maybe
they're still under the age of 18. Maybe
they're in their 20s or 30s. They've
already left the house. I want to
encourage you that you can continue to
pray for your child. The impact of
social media is strong, but it pales in
comparison to what the Holy Spirit can
do.
>> Amen.
>> The Holy Spirit can still move hearts.
And when you pray, Roger Mno talks about
this in his books, um, Incredible
Answers to Prayers.
>> Pray and say, "Lord, I give you
permission to work on the heart of this
young person, on my child, on my
grandchild, on my nephew, niece, church
members, child, whatever it is. I give
you permission." Because the devil's
going to say, "You have no right to this
child,
>> Jesus. no right to this child because
this child doesn't want anything to do
with you. They're into Dungeons and
Dragons and Harry Potter. They want
nothing to do with you. But but God can
respond and say, "But no, one of my own
says,
>> I can work on this child."
>> Yeah.
>> And the those rules of engagement apply
and and God can begin to work on that
child. And I that's I kind of want to
make sure we leave with the hope that
look, God still fixes things.
>> That's right. Amen. And and we've done a
couple pieces on our channel about um
spiritual warfare. Um we had a guy um
David Young that came on and talked
about phenomenal and and and talked
about just spiritual warfare and and um
Tim Maddox also talked about it. And
what was interesting was they brought up
the concept of like um like generational
curses, right? So these are things that
the devil um lays claim on this family
because hey, guess what? Their
grandparents were into witchcraft, so
now I can mess with them and down the
line, right? But think about this from
the reverse. God's very fair, right?
What if you're on God's side? Now
you you can pray that God has victory
with your children. Hey, look God. I'm
serving you and I'm I'm doing this. Help
win this down the road with my children
and their children. And take this verse
right here at Isaiah 49 and just say,
I'm holding this to you, God. This is a
promise. You told me you would save my
children, and I believe that God is a
man of his word.
>> I call it the legacy of faith. And you
see it in second Timothy. I think it's
chapter chapter 1 and verse 5. He says,
he says to Timothy, he says, "And I and
I know the unfeigned faith," speaking to
Timothy, "that is in you, that was in
your grandmother Lois and in your mother
Ununice."
>> Example,
>> speaks of the legacy of faith. And I say
to young people, when I talk to young
people, I say, "Do not squander that
legacy."
>> That is a powerful legacy. And some of
you just came into the church, you know,
you you don't have generations of
Christians behind you or Adventists
behind you. That's fine. Start the
legacy. That's right.
>> Right. Right. And for those of us who
were raised second, third, fourth
generations in this church, those
numbers mean nothing
>> if it is not if if you're not in Christ
and powered by the Holy Spirit. That's
right.
>> That's the legacy. And so I like how you
said it. It works in reverse.
>> And so, you know, we talk a lot about
social media. It is ubiquitous. It's
dangerous, but it still pales in
comparison to the power of our God.
>> Amen.
>> Um, one other verse I wanted to just
just to just to speak to um social
media. Luke 9:23. And he said unto them,
"If any man will come after me, let him
deny himself
>> and take up his cross daily and follow
me." So I look at this as the mandate on
how to interact with with the world and
social media and everything else is, you
know, I've got to deny myself because it
feels really good to sit there and
scroll and be entertained by these
little short videos. Um the the and we
didn't talk about this, but the average
attention span has just shrunk down.
They said that when YouTube and stuff
first came out, the videos were 45
minutes an hour and people would watch
them. And now they've come up with
YouTube shorts and shorts because the
videos have to be shorter and shorter
and shorter because people just can't
watch long and it's just a deluge of
stuff. I can't like everybody's face,
everybody's just it's just too much
information. It's just too much
information.
>> So, we do need to deny ourselves, take
up our cross, and follow Jesus. A a a a
good thing to keep in mind is when
you're using social media, um just pay
attention to how you use it. Are you
using it by looking at constantly your
own things or your own life or you're
comparing it or whatever or are you
using it to bless other people?
>> I mean, you can take that same
technology and go, you know what, Eric
Walsh gave this amazing sermon over here
and I need to share this with somebody
over here. Like, this would be a
blessing to you in your life. If you're
using it to pass information around,
that is a great use of the technology.
and and just be cognizant of that. You
know, it's like use the whatever you
have to share and spread God's message.
He is giving a last message of mercy.
Amen. And as you as you I'm sure
everybody will agree, we are speeding
towards the end like on a bullet train
and uh we've got moments left to talk
>> and I think sharing that's one of the
other good good points to to to
highlight. Share when you find good
things. So, like David Ing's um stuff, I
sent that to
>> Awesome.
>> everybody because I said, "Listen,
there's a lot of families that don't
know why,
>> you know, certain things are happening."
>> Yeah. Or how to deal with it.
>> And he and or how to deal with it. And
his testimony and his the six-part one
that was on audio verse first and then
now there's a three-part one.
>> I I was like, "People need to see this.
Adventists need to see this. They have
to understand where we really are in the
spiritual warfare and so they can begin
to arm themselves because again I think
the enemy is only going to get more
brazen, more bold,
>> more direct,
>> more dangerous.
>> Yep. That's right.
[Music]